hi guys it's silverette again and with
another episode of Silver City and you
know what it is because you clicked on
the video and you've seen the title and
all that but yeah as you can see right
now I am building a somewhat weird
looking building that is because I
figured I'm building the city but all
the buildings look kind of good in a
sense though I I wouldn't want to say
that so um let's just say that all the
buildings are probably a bit um too high
class to actually be realistic so I
figured H you need some ugly buildings
in the city as well so I just um on
purpose decided to create an ugly
building which is what I'm doing right
now it's like one of those weird brick
concrete things that you don't want to
see in a city yet they're everywhere or
something like that I don't know exactly
what the situation in in like American
cities is I I kind of have some
stereotypes and some cliches in my head
of which many of them actually turned
out to be true that was very funny
especially like the stuff about the
American flags and the street lights and
and the buildings and all that but yeah
basically this means that this building
is not going to be quite the most
interesting thing ever to look at and
also not to look at me building now
that's a good thing because I have
plenty of things to talk about and um
because many things have been happening
in my life um vacation right now I
haven't done anything it's almost over I
need to go to school tomorrow again and
I haven't done anything like I haven't
done any school work even though I have
a test week so that's going to that's
going to be some major problems and um
well I haven't really done loads of
things rc3 related either I've been kind
of addicted to Minecraft and then this
morning I loaded my save file and it got
corrupted because of update and I lost
everything so I cried then I played Sim
City and then Sim City crashed and I
lost everything and then I cried and
then I was like oh roller coaster Eon 3
I'll I'll come back to you don't worry
so yeah that kind of happened and then
there was the fact that um I had to
celebrate my I had to well not really
like that but I celebrated my birthday
yesterday and um so I still have a sore
throat and I burn my I burnt my tongue
and um speaking hurts and yeah basically
but it was loads of fun it was really
awesome so um holy life has been
amazing as of lately except I need to go
to school again tomorrow but yeah
basically back to Roller Co roller yeah
back to roller coaster I 3 because
that's the game that I'm playing I well
this was a little parking lot I've
actually been talking to people and I
was like can I actually do this because
as it turns out well obviously I I build
like these buildings in these squares
and then I get empty space in the middle
of them so I figured me might as well
put parking lots in them so I asked some
um Americans about their parking lot
experiences but they were like M you can
do that so I was like yeah thank you
very much that really helped me no but
yeah I'm just going to just going to
keep this I kind of like the idea though
like I don't have other places where I'd
really put one and then speaking of
stereotypes I was like might as well
throw an American house in there just to
make sure that everyone knows that this
is an American city I don't know if that
really makes sense but I I definitely
perhaps should have well practiced more
with this because I haven't really done
that and you can probably tell because
I'm not I don't really know where
everything is in this set and how
American houses work and I definitely
need to look for some pictures of and
stuff like that though in the end this
house didn't come out all that bad I
kind of like it especially the the shape
and where it's at right there like I I
don't know I just like the placement
with the parking lot and stuff like that
it's not all that bad either but I feel
like H I still feel like it has a bit of
a derpy look not exactly what I was
looking for it's it's the problem that I
have well I don't really have something
in my head it's usually I I come up with
something in my head and then I tried to
kind of build that in roller coaster o 3
but with the American H style I just had
something in my head but it was nothing
more than a vag idea and I just randomly
placed some walls in roller coaster e 3
and hoped for the best so considering
that I did it like that it actually came
out very well so um that's actually a
good thing now over here I started work
on a new skyscraper and yeah this is
already the third building of the
episode so loads of stuff is going on
here and this skyscraper is going to be
the second skyscraper it's not nearly
going to be as tall as the first one and
it's not very not very complicated
honestly I just wanted some well fancy
um antiquish Classic Building that I
would put on the Square and especially
that little Gallery I love those things
like the the classic well pillar
thingies I don't know I don't know what
do you call them you have them
everywhere in Italy but basically
they're awesome so I decided that I
would make one of those things and then
just attach a skyscraper on to it just
because I I can I guess well it didn't
come out that bad you'll see in a couple
of minutes so yeah the skyscrape is just
going to be a somewhat Simple Thing uh I
I I didn't build it based on anything I
just decided to randomly place down
walls and hope for the best once again
but it actually turned out into
something that kind of looks like it's
been inspired by certain buildings in
Rotterdam though that's not necessarily
A Bad Thing
and uh it looks pretty good I guess I've
been getting some feedback because uh
there's a minor delay over a couple of
days between episode between actually
recording episodes and then uploading
them so of course as soon as I finish an
episode I go crazy and show everyone on
Skype and all that like oh look at this
new building I made so that's really
awesome and thank you community for
being very supportive and all that and
we're just all being friends and all
that uh so that's really awesome but
yeah this Tower I just felt like H I
need something something glossy and then
I want to connect something with bricks
and normal Windows to that so that's
what I decided to go for and with really
no other plan in in the back of my head
I just decided to go for it and now that
pretty much turned into this though I'm
still not a very big big fan of the
shape just the the the glass is a bit
too wide I wish that roller coaster tyon
3 would have actually allowed me to get
some quarter tile glass stuff that I so
I would actually be able to make the
glass part just ever so SM so slightly
um smaller than the actual brick part so
the actual main frame of the building
but I couldn't do that so it's a sad day
for everyone but except it's not really
a sad day because it didn't come out
that
bad and this is just me again working
with that closet which I do have to well
kind of watch out for that I don't
overuse that too much which I will do in
the series yeah I think this is almost
the only glass set that I really use
simply because the texture is so good
and there so many different shapes and
sizes and all that and you have all the
curves and diagonal pieces and slanted
pieces so it's a really awesome set so
really I I just can't not use it that's
basically how that works and then I
decided to add the same old windows from
shy guys Main Street
because they're awesome once again I've
been kind of overusing those things but
I don't think there's really a way of
getting around that they're just too
good not to use them you know might as
well overuse things if they're good then
why not go for it I guess and at that
point I I thought like maybe I can add
some stuff to this but it just turns out
that nothing really works the the either
too fancy or not fancy enough so I just
decided to keep it as is and um decided
to add some little details to the floor
over there because it didn't have any
Windows yet nor did the paths have
borders so I really needed to add
that and at that point that thing is
pretty much finished and then I was like
hm what's the next thing I could do and
I I just suddenly felt like making
trains so figured I would have a go at
making a train station because I've I
read all the comments and I reply to
them honestly um YouTube is a community
um you should read your comments and
reply to them because that's kind of
like okay no sorry um okay I won't do
that again I'm I'm going to save you my
YouTube RS but basically so people are
um suggesting um like Subways and other
ways of public
transportation and I felt
like maybe my town is way too small to
do that stuff and I figured I would
actually um try and make a train station
because even if your town is somewhat
smaller you're always going to have a
train station it's a very common way of
Transport at least in Europe and I'm
pretty sure it also played a major role
in the development of America so I'm
just going to go America okay sorry God
so I figured I would just try it and
yeah that's basically me building a
train station it's nothing too
complicated it's a very simple train
station in terms of design and the way
it works basically it's just some it's
it's two Y what do you even call those
things I don't even know you the two
like boarding platforms that that sounds
way too official that sounds like it's a
it's a rocket like out of space and all
that I don't know but basically cool and
I like doing that because I could place
benches and lights and add flowers and
as soon as I can add flowers to anything
my day is already perfect so thank you
train station it was actually it was
actually fun to design that little train
station just because I just like the
general idea of making small platforms
and kind of adding decorations to them
and then came the main station building
now of course in the series because I'm
making a entire city well not really an
entire city but a part of a city I
figured that I I wouldn't do any
Interiors but I did want to do like a
general exterior of the train station
and now I've seen a couple of train
stations in my life and um this one is
most of all well somewhat inspired by
the main station of Rotterdam in terms
of shape and all that yet for some
reason I actually at the training
station of Rome in the back of my head
while designing this and it really
doesn't look like the latter at all it's
definitely something like the shape of
the Rotterdam train station especially
with that triangle occurring is
basically what it kind of looks like so
it's more like that so that's what it
turned into and this is just the the
main frame I decided to build this main
frame with the roof and the supports and
then build the actual building within
that and add glass to the main frame or
something like that so it's very simple
in um structure but it's something that
I felt like I had to come up with and I
wasn't sure whether it would actually
work well but I think it turned out
pretty okay in the end yeah so of course
this is just that hair pulling glass
editing stuff that you really need to do
and decided to go in a for a different
blue color simply because the dark blue
just looked a bit too dark and I feel
like this color is pretty safe now I
need to say even though I do like the
general look and shape and all of that
jazz of the station I still feel like
there is some lack of detail and I know
that I always want detail in all of my
builds but I still feel like the station
is a bit too simple and know I'm not
going to add random frames to the
windows because I've already been doing
that everywhere and I feel like I
shouldn't do that I just feel like some
different textures or other things
should be added to this thing and
um now that I'm talking about that and
there's something that I really need to
talk about that I should have uh
realized beforehand and I kind of forgot
and I feel really guilty about this now
and I'm not going to record this episode
again but I'm using my new headset and
um that means that I'm using a different
mic than I usually am and you could
probably tell at the beginning of this
video because you could probably hear a
very slight buzzing behind my voice when
I talk that's because I have a buzzing
noise background noise problem and um I
can use audacity and noise remove all
that but you're still going to have a
very slight buzz in the background
whenever I talk now this is because I
have a ground loop with my headset and
my crappy laptop and the crappy um
electricity Network that we have and um
no I did take my laptop out of the um
out of the adapter and I took my mouse
out and everything basically everything
that's connected to my laptop except my
headset still have a ground loop I don't
know why it's really annoying and as
soon as I place my hand on my laptop the
ground Loop is gone but but the problem
is that I'm stupid I'm very stupid and I
make so many hand gestures even though I
shouldn't do that because I'm doing a
let's play I still make them so my hand
is not on my laptop honestly it should
be on my laptop to prevent the ground Lo
from happening but it wasn't simply
because I'm stupid and I want to talk in
a very natural way and I move my entire
body and I'm basically dancing to the
words that I'm saying right now so sorry
for that background noise but I can't
bother to record this episode again
apparent especially with my throat
because I ruined my throat um yesterday
night and I really can't bother to ruin
it again because I have school tomorrow
and um I'm not going to quite dare that
but anyway back to roller coaster tyon 3
the station is finished and I'm working
on a new building and um now I've
noticed this later on but this building
is probably way too similar to the
building on the other side now at the
time I felt like this is something that
I want simply because when you look at
cities like arome and Bucharest and all
that you have all these squares and you
have symmetrical buildings around them
and it looks so awesome but then I
realized this is a modern American city
Modern American cities are not going to
to what the dictators in Europe did with
their buildings so I probably shouldn't
have done this even though it looks kind
of fancy to have symmetrical buildings
in in a sense on both sides and those
nice little arcs and everything uh I
probably shouldn't have done this but
I'm still going to keep it I mean looks
good may it may not be realistic but I
still feel like probably still um
aesthetically Aesthetics Aesthetics um
well are more important than realism in
a sense simply because I can always hide
behind the excuse of I am creating a
perfect City and not necessarily a
realistic one but one that I would want
to see and one of which I really like
the way it looks even though I shouldn't
say that because it's not safe because
you should never set goals for yourself
to create a perfect or a beautiful
something because one you should boast
about yourself like that but also you
can't create something that's perfect
and so you shouldn't strive for it
either really I don't see the point in
that like how can you strive for
something impossible you should at least
set a goal that you can actually do and
that's actually somewhat human to do I
guess and yeah that by the way I just
added two windows to that building
because I saw that the wall was entirely
white and I was like oh yeah there I
forgot those windows time to add those
things because before I forget it and
then just some small details on that
little building so that it looks a bit
more like the building on the other side
of the same street and you have that
nice symmetry going on and beautiful
beautiful symmetry I love Symmetry and
especially the Symmetry that's not
exactly symmetrical so then it's kind of
like a fake symmetry that's beautiful so
that you don't see it right away but
then you start noticing details and it's
like two pictures that you have to look
at and then see the see the differences
anyway uh that's it for this episode
with so many buildings actually and
thank you for watching and see you in
the next
one